[Music]
okay you know I'm nervous down like
Alfred I he I love him very much
I know him you know him we all got
Alford's I used to try to like juggle
try to figure out what his side was is
he a cancer cuz you know is he a Virgo
yeah I feel like he's a cancer
oh no dis the caster's Jon know how your
locker
I know watch you Donna's gonna be like
actually that's wrong he is a Pisces and
like damn what you call you our group
man we didn't migos and then landed it
with poppin I don't know where nearest
that is what do I know and you know they
were late y'all asked so six to seven
hours late however when they got there
they hit it they hit it like quavo like
hit like it was unlike anything I've
ever seen man and like I was actually in
awe like I'm just like how malleable
were and how playful they were and I'm
willing it were to just dive in and be
careful out there man I wear how we got
to see them mix again through these
amigos you know I'm a trot boy like I
gotta go meet my plugs one of their guys
the starts to come and be like we have a
new vocation and then I are following to
the location yet who knew foreshadowing
woods again and they're like in an RV
like I want to tell you I didn't know
where we were gonna like seriously that
when we got on set I was like there's
none of our V isn't that a campfire who
does mind of girls why she reading the
book
as somebody hostage and the in Darius
watch the murder this person right in
front of us what really had a firearm we
really had to light and it was hot
because it was like one of those old
like hunting wife was where you got a
light click so like he had to keep
shooting this thing over and over again
yeah it was a yeah crazy a man my bad
father good man may say he was straight
we are some weird [ __ ] about somewhere
oh god bless keep that name cuz we just
kept looking and it was called what it
was freezing it just kept looking each
other like this is not worth it like
Alfred like change the game and get a
different do something different
[Applause]
you know it's really interesting is like
I never thought that the invisible car
will be as big as it was because you
know it was just one of those struttin
moments you know like Here I am having
this beef you know Marcus miles is
stunting with a peacock and buying
everything at bar I'm just over it
the club will complete the most like
absurd thing for Alfred to be upset
about [ __ ] him - its Marcus mouths
pretty cool you know he got that
invisible car I just think it's one of
those moments of just like those trends
where people are like constantly putting
things on social media be like well look
at this man even when I watch I forget
that it's coming up and I'm just like
yes so no
I mean when they tell you these people
flew over this car I was just like oh
God oh no one's about that we didn't
like insurance about to be how I like
there being hit by a real car like the
car I think was covered like in green
screen or like you know that material
Big Ups Atlanta stunt teams because like
it's not easy especially if you black
and you doing stunts it's not enough of
us out there but they flew over this car
you see those people flying that is
literally they got some they got some
air up there man you know you get this
script that says ba in on it and you
don't really know what that means and I
just remember opening it and it was like
we opened on a Dodge Charger going down
the side and I was like huh and then
he's like okay then the talk show huh
and then like okay like so we just went
with it that's the thing about our
universe we don't really have any rules
we don't really have any you know we
just go for it the episode right before
that was value and then you want kind of
want answers about what's going on in
the previous episode and then we come in
and we're like psych just gonna like
throw these fake commercials in there
and then we're gonna throw like the
coconut crunch shows at you let's go sir
let's go we're gonna throw the Dodge
Charger at you which is annoying because
every time I rent a car they will always
give me a Dodge Charger like in New York
they like look at me with this like
great like just this happiness of like
okay all right like everything better
work in this damn car
[Music]
I think in that particular show is that
Montague in particular was digging for
stuff like he was trying to find a way
to cause a dissension amongst the ranks
and especially with our hip-hop artists
that you already think is uneducated you
already think it's a thug you already
think isn't you know just a person of
the people and because this woman is a
doctor of this you instantly decide to
turn your back on your own and then you
notice we're very reflective of the
generation we're in with social media
you can say something on Twitter and all
of a sudden Twitter fingers it's just
boom I mean everybody has a repercussion
except my president but you know I'm
saying like you know when you put things
on social media it's out there forever
there's no way to take it back with
Alfred's case you know he loves filters
he loves getting on Twitter he loves
like he what's out like his eggs off
that [ __ ] I think that it was a wake-up
moment for him being like okay I gotta
be real careful not before I got can't
be as frivolous as I thought some people
found your remarks offensive yeah well
freedom of speech no you're right
I agree you hate women what I think that
that was the greatest one of the
greatest things that happen or that came
out of that meeting between the two of
them is that we actually did agree they
don't want us to do that how dare we
agree like what what if the liberals and
conservatives actually were like hey man
you got I feel you on that one
definitely one that what too late there
would be nowhere for us to go and I
think there'd be plenty place for us to
go please welcome
Antoine smalls to the show hello
Montague I didn't know that that dude
was gonna be actually sitting on set in
front of me with this blonde wig on and
sitting there talking about how it's
okay for me as a rapper and a black man
to say the things that I say but then be
against same-sex marriage and trenchant
I was like you've got to be but I
couldn't get over the fact that we're
listening to this idiot who had this
blond wig on
I just remember looking at Donald and I
was like can I go wait did you power up
cuz you look like Super Saiyan right now
like is that like is that the Goku that
Dragonball collection might like you
look like a fake Ellen DeGeneres like a
felon DeGeneres all right we're gonna
know you look like Drake Malfoy dude
like bangs like nobody told you I was
just so angry so angry at this dude
coming out here in this mop man and I'm
like I just couldn't but that was fun
and we did that in one day like that
like my section of it was one day I'm a
35 year old white man we have no problem
making things as uncomfortable just just
shy of you being like but that's what it
is you know I mean that's how this
landscape is in a in a way especially in
Atlanta you know and being black in this
world like there's so many things that
just gets pushed to this point where
you're just like ah hey excuse me what I
PA do you have one tab hey did you see
game of firms last night yeah but then
you know we we like that because you at
least you know you're president at least
you know you're feeling something if you
take away something from it fine if you
don't cool at least we still made you go
you know we wanted to sit with you so
man definitely sat with people
[Laughter]
ah tough guys I'm Zen whoo so Zen Zen
the stand is a column stalker fan is a
huge fan of paperboy but I don't even
think it's just being a huge fan of
paper boy
I think it's him being a fan of Fame and
being a fan of what that means I'm a
photographer man I took this how's your
fish neck school but I felt like Alfred
was that a low point in his life because
here he is performing at these clubs
that he doesn't want to perform at this
dude is going on the internet saying
things about him and then like it just
because I didn't take a hat or something
like that and this actor was fantastic
but man was he method like hey he made
sure to be right by my side man like I
would turn around he'd be right there
and I'm just like what's going on but I
mean like everything you do everyone has
access to he was a representation of
what that fandom meant and what that
success means and how people watch your
every move and now people will troll and
try to just just try to want you to
catch case however you try to play me
out here and didn't think that I
wouldn't show up at your job and beat
your ass is what you didn't think but he
gave us a paperboy a message as well
he's like yeah I'm exploiting you
exploiting rap music in you were
exploiting that and we all got to do it
I mean it's true you're exploiting your
situation to make rap and I'm exploiting
you exploiting that money broth season
two especially was particularly
difficult to accept the fate of what
Fame it
and that was the thing where then is
like it was a testament of like you
can't really be mad at this do because
they take a look at his life and then
look at stories like what why are you
really worried about him Woods just
exasperated breath woods okay
Woods thank you Stephanie Robinson rut
was yeah and hero directed when
Stephanie told me that she she didn't
exactly tell me what the episode was
about because there's a protection you
know
I think everyone was trying to protect
me and I just remember sitting hero down
and I was like real quick this woods
episode is it about my mother
that's like just just rip it off man and
he didn't say anything he's just not it
was that cool is my mother's presence in
this episode it's not it was like cool
do I talk to her no you know that whole
thing by being the tough person and
being there when everybody else's chips
are down and being there you know this
one day it's just one day that he needed
and people were checking up on him but I
think it was like Alfred what are you
gonna do okay what are you gonna do she
is not here
hey regardless of if she is not here and
now you're in this land that you don't
know and is dangerous got mugged
he literally almost got killed and the
concept of how close he got that that
close to death just about walking the
street was terrifying and being lost in
the woods in a place that he knows
there's a shot that hero did that just
like when his hands up over the woods
and it just keeps going and he just
keeps going all four sides of your
television screen it just it just keeps
going and just keeps going that's
literally what grief feels like that's
literally what it feels like you
literally feel like somebody dropped you
in this forest and this land that you
know so well it dropped you you don't
know which way is in and which way is
out you don't know I just remember the
collaboration that we had on this one
man you know like there was one point
that there was supposed to be a Zippo
lighter I was supposed to have a lighter
getting through the woods I was like no
man I don't think he needs that it needs
to be dark
he wouldn't push me that that hard
because he just like he knew I was gonna
just go with it but I ran through these
woods I remember like really being
terrified that someone was shooting at
me and jumping behind this log for
safety and breaking the law at whole
like I don't know what I was gonna do
with that thing I was like but if it
comes to it I got a
myself and when I got beat up I was like
hey nice cars like what did it be like a
warrant it's not he just head-butted
somebody and I guess the night goes on I
wanted to get more infected and more
just just bigger and just like and then
is he hearing what he's hearing is the
whistling there like like there's
imminent threats make the decision keep
standing still you're gone boy you're
wasting time
and the only people who get time ah dead
what that crazy person said was right
but I think after that you see the
Alfred got it
like really got it Hey
excuse me
are you favorable remember this kid I
didn't know was gonna be a white kid
either think I didn't know and he comes
up and I was like yeah man like because
he sees I mean I know he sees it but the
day is still paper boy right there and I
think that that was the moment that you
see him go oh hold up though like you
have to do this and smile it tell them
how to hold the camera and tell them
where to be and because you know you
don't want your fans to see that you're
hurting that way because this is the
person that's kind of like make make you
do what you do and love what you do I'm
really glad that people responded to it
the way they did because I could have
gotten in such a dark place man I don't
know was the most cathartic thing that
ever happened I apologize I apologize
but it saved my life
this show has saved my life and it
helped me a lot to get through what that
grief is and get closer to those
relationships that you have because you
don't know how long you have it o GQ how
dare you how dare you man
but yeah it sticks with me and it
totally was the most life-changing
experience in my way baby
Robert was great that actor was
absolutely great method as well so
anytime you see me it's real but I have
to remember that I need my damn haircut
man and I'm gonna coming to you since
the beginning bruh and like you going to
see I think one of my favorite moans oh
are you Hollywood oh you Hollywood now
huh nah man this is so right up for me
in a magazine I used to write for the
magazine and they want me to take some
pictures so this he will go off the cuff
and just say what he's taking and just
go and go and go
but do
sheer gall man to drag me over its town
with the cape on wit like then you like
because it's like half a haircut man
like so you know my fault whose fault is
it
it's his bow you always got some type of
excuse manage don't know excuse this
time
seriously this is his phone he comin to
my this cold broke danghang come about
and i was on my way home you I had
totally said could I help him I was like
now I gotta go do the right thing you
know I'm sayin we start crying stuff
come out his engine yeah Cui's engine or
something like that his corporate head
jaundice so I had to go and pick him up
on side of the road you know there's a
shock I don't never forget cuz this is
what I love about Donald's director too
is you don't know what him in here that
you don't never know what they're gonna
keep there'll be cameras set up but you
don't ever really know what's going and
there's a moment that I'm like looking
in the rearview and I look to see just
to check to see I'll I'm like oh damn so
it constantly is that it constantly
keeps it constantly as a discovery along
the way Zak's peas no leftovers no I
mean I did eat the chicken wings and the
sauce and part of bread but the chicken
tenders for dinner bar you my man
take me back to the shop when I got in
the car with him in like things just I
just remember looking at him cuz I had
to get in the mode of not liking this
dude and all I said to him I was like
whatever happens you're driving okay so
that's the road
he's a great man thinking I was like if
I can give you anything that's the road
and so when that scene happens where his
son is in the back of his talk in Robert
was really like not he was real and I
was like and someone using me go baby
the road man a baby the right like it
was
could you please stop skipping school so
could you not check out my girl oh [ __ ]
the barbershop was a barber shop was was
tough was also even greater is like any
time you see me in a car it doesn't
necessarily mean that I was filming it
that day so I had this hard task this
season now of doing all these car scenes
from different episodes back to back to
back so I did a car scene from north of
the border with Donald and Keith Tracy
then right after that I did a car scene
with Sierra from woods then I ended the
day with Bibby
so I was going through a gamut of
emotions like I was going all day just
like wait where am i what happened
I'm interested to see where he goes I
want him to win so bad I wanted to win
so bad and I think he's getting there I
think now he's having the power
discernment to understand who needs to
be there who doesn't even if they're
family and so yeah I think he's getting
there